uh so one of the features of being human
is that we're mortal we die uh we've
talked about AI a lot about potentially
replicas of ourselves uh do you think
there will be AI replicas of you and me
that persists long after we're gone
that family and loved ones can talk to
I think we'll have the capacity to do
something like that and I think one of
the big questions
that we've had to struggle with in the
context of
social networks is who gets to make that
um and you know and my answer to that
you know in the context of the work that
we're doing is that that should be your
choice right I don't think anyone should
be able to choose to make a Lex spot
that people can
can choose to talk to and get to train
that yeah and we've kind of we have this
precedent of making some of these calls
where
I mean someone can create a page for a
a Lex fan club but you can't create a
page and say that you relax yes right
um
so I think that this similarly I think
and maybe you know someone maybe can
make a
should be able to make an AI That's um
that's a Lex admirer that someone can
talk to you but I think it should
ultimately be your call
whether
there is a Lex AI well I'm open sourcing
The Lex
[Laughter]